بدا شبان رحلتهما في البيتكوين العام
الماضي
احدهما كان يعمل 12 ساعه يوميا يراقب
الرسوم البيانيه ويطارد كل شمعه خضراء
الليله الماضيه تسبب فخ الحيتان واحد في
محو حسابه بكامل
اما الرجل الاخر فقد قضى امسيته مع عائلته
ورشف قهوته واستيقظ على ريت قدره 5000
دولار
الفرق لم يكن حظا بل كان النظام
احدهما كان يصطاد والاخر كان يدافع
يفشل معظم المتداولين لانهم يعتقدون ان
التداول يدور حول الشراء
الامر ليس كذلك
التداول يدور حول عدم الوقوع في الفخاخ
في سوق البيتكين انتم مستهدف من قبل
المؤسسات
بدون درع تصبح عواطفك اسوا عدو لك تشعر
بالخوف من ضياع الفرصه تضغط على شراء
فينطبق الفخ عليك تراب ديفينس بي تي سي
يغير كل شيء محركنا يكشف الفخاخ غير
المرئيه التي ينصبها الحيتام
نحن نعلمك اقوى مهاره في العالم الانباط
لعدم فعل اي شيء بنسبه 70% من الوقت عندما
تتحرك اخيرا
تتحرك بيقيم نسبته 90%
انه دفاع عالي الدقه لسوق عالي المخاطر لا
تكن المتداول الذي يخسر كل شيء كن الشخص
الذي يظل مخميا
قم بتفعيل بروتوكول الدفاع الخاص بك ادناه
مرحبا بك في الاكاديميه ‏Ja.